[Music]
the sight of a pointed dorsal fin
peeking out above the water immediately
evokes our fight or flight response but
should sharks really cause humans so
much anxiety or did we sensationalize
and demonize a fish into a monster
not to mention those people who have a
general phobia of the ocean called
phlasophobia the inability to see what
is below a fear of drowning of darkness
of the unknown these fears helped create
a lot of sea monsters both real and
imagined throw in a carnivorous fish and
it's easy to make a real animal a
monster and a lot of people have
capitalized on that with the shark
yet despite the rarity of shark attacks
on humans these animals have an
unwarranted reputation as bloodthirsty
man-eaters and you can largely thank
horror movies for the bad pr
so if sharks are not naturally
aggressive towards humans why did we
turn a fish that kills fewer people a
year than falling coconuts and bee
stings into such an iconic killer
i'm dr emily zarka and this
is monstrum
the idea of the shark as a monster is
certainly linked to their powerful jaws
muscular bodies and celebrated olfactory
abilities not to mention those teeth i
find a lot of sharks cute but even i
don't want to see those pearly whites up
close
they are powerful creatures that remind
humans we are not the animals at the top
of the food chain perhaps fear of sharks
is simply a lingering biological
response to the possibility of being
eaten by these capable hunters
still sharks don't hunt and eat humans
unlike some lions and other big cats
bears or hell even pythons yet they
frequently terrorize us on the big
screen and in newspapers alike there are
few shark type monsters out there in
mythology and folklore like the japanese
yokai iso nade the classical greek
monster cilla with its many heads and
three rows of shark-like teeth or the
primordial sea monster zipli from
mesoamerican mythology but there are far
more shark deities although some like
the hawaiian nanawe could fall into
either category the polynesian peoples
both feared and revered sharks in some
stories there are monstrous sharks that
eat people but there are also stories of
sharks possessed by ancestral spirits
rescuing humans according to other
legends some chiefs kept pet sharks who
recognize members of the family
in africa along the west coast some
cultures included shark meat as part of
their diet while others saw them as
sacred
either way they learned how to live
alongside the shark since respect was
paramount
we start to see sharks in a more
predominantly negative light from
european sources around the 16th century
in 1553 spanish historian francisco
lopez di gamora recounted spanish
conquistador hernan cortez's conquest of
mexico which included the conqueror's
interaction with sharks describing them
as insatiable and capable of swallowing
anything
while further describing sharks it was
written that they will attack a cow or
horse grazing or drinking at the river's
edge and will eat a man
slave trade sailors heard of the choke
from the maya of the caribbean and
turned the word to shark around the 16th
century written historical records from
slave ships mentioned sharks along with
other fish swimming alongside the boats
eager to eat whatever was thrown
overboard from excrement to people in
the 18th century abolitionists used
violent images of sharks eating africans
thrown overboard from slave ships to
further emphasize the horrors of the
slave trade
artists immortalized these haunting
images
more visual depictions of shark
encounters appeared after a cabin boy
named brook watson fell overboard and
had his leg bitten off by a shark in
havana cuba the incident became the
inspiration for a famous painting watson
and the shark
then in the mid 19th century human shark
encounters became a more popular fixture
on the global news circuit when the
birkenhead steamer sank newspapers
reported that hundreds of sharks
occupying the surrounding reefs laid
devastation to the survivors
according to survivor benjamin turner
who was a child at the time of the wreck
a shark would come up seize them by the
leg and drag them down
these vivid testimonies and the
accompanying images led to one of the
first media representations of a
so-called feeding frenzy
still sharks were considered relatively
harmless until the 20th century a series
of human shark encounters in new jersey
in 1916 led to major newspapers labeling
the animals as so-called man-eating
monsters causing a wave of panic
around the same time on the other side
of the world in australia surfing was
gaining popularity as more humans
entered into shark habitats the news
began to pay attention to fatal
encounters
public and political outcry led to the
meshing of metropolitan beaches nets
were installed along the coastline to
catch sharks that got too close in 1958
the shark attack file was founded to
document global shark encounters
overwhelmingly however sharks were still
at the periphery of consciousness for
most until jaws
the famous film is based on a 1974 novel
of the same name inspired in part by
those 1916 new jersey events when the
film adaptation hit theaters in 1975 it
was accompanied by massive fanfare
jaws defined the summer blockbuster it
helped launch steven spielberg's career
gave us one of the most iconic movie
scores of all time and made a whole lot
of people terrified to go into the water
we can partially thank universal studios
marketing team for that inspiring fear
seemed to be their driving strategy it
is as if god
created the devil
and gave him
jaws
teasers of the film ran on tv to the
tune of 700 000
and merchandise with the iconic film
poster was created the fact that people
didn't have much knowledge about sharks
made it easy for the media to exploit
fear of the unknown
that fear taps into not just being prey
but how you might become prey in other
words the jaws of jaws is what really
freaks us out
[Music]
jaws also plays on fears and guilt of
war comments on mass hysteria and
criticizes the reckless scientist
comparisons of the film's mayor to the
disgraced president richard nixon
indicate parallels between the shark
cover-up and watergate
and then there's the freudian reading of
a giant male predator engaging in a
little voyeurism before attacking a
naked woman but there's also the
feminist reading that sees the shark as
a metaphor of the monstrous feminine and
or the folkloric myth of vagina dentata
regardless of how you interpret the film
it's indisputable that the great white
shark at its center is meant to be the
monster
[Music]
you're gonna need a bigger boat
a lot went wrong during the filming of
jaws including rough ocean waters bad
weather and the mechanical shark's
frequent malfunctions
nicknamed bruce after spielberg's lawyer
the animatronic shark used in the film
was notoriously finicky the exposure to
saltwater and martha's vineyard led to
the mechanic's erosion and even greater
unpredictability
but these turned out to be what bob ross
might call happy little accidents the
inability to show the metal puppet on
screen contributed to its mysterious
menace we don't see the full shark until
more than halfway through the movie
in some ways jaws feels like an
extension of the kaiju and big bug film
genres with a little more horror and
action thrown in alongside hitchcockian
thriller for good measure it's man vs
nature with a slasher flick twist
post jaws sharks were handed the dubious
title of monsters of the deep it
probably didn't help that jaws author
peter benchley knew very little about
sharks and most people took the film's
portrayal of a fictional shark monster
as the normal behavior of real great
white sharks immediately after the
film's release beachgoers headed inland
damaging coastal town economies shark
fishing competitions became a thing
despite the panic and the damage to
sharks the movie caused it also inspired
future scientists and the public to
learn more about sharks in general
eventually by the way he became a vocal
shark conservationist
solidified and popularized the
perspective of sharks as monsters and
ushered in the shark exploitation genre
as digital special effects emerged in
the 1990s monster shark films became
even more popular we can't seem to get
enough as special effects improved films
began to make the shark even scarier by
making them bigger
much bigger enter the megalodon the idea
of the prehistoric fish surviving
extinction was introduced in the jaws
book when hooper an oceanographer
speculates that the titular massive
white shark is likely a smaller version
of a creature lurking far deeper down in
the ocean
he mentions megalodons and questions if
they are extinct
in 1997 another author would pick up on
that thread and expand it literally
meg a novel of deep terror by stephen
alton follows a scientist diving the
mariana trench on behalf of the u.s navy
who sees a megalodon and spends the rest
of his captain ahem-esque life trying to
prove it exists
the book opens with an awesome scene of
a t-rex getting eaten by a megalodon
unfortunately the magbucks film
adaptation in 2018 didn't include that
scene but it did give us jason statham
underwater fighting a fairly impressive
cgi shark
while in the past the media latched onto
the sensational with the meg we got the
requisite monster shark attention but
with a side of science mac tracker is
live great reel em in dj
the overwhelming majority of scientists
insist the megalodon is indeed extinct
for millions of years in fact not hiding
in the modern depths of the mariana
trench
plus the movie shark version is chunkier
longer and tolerates cold water better
than the real thing as for its
resemblance to a great white shark
evidence suggests megalodons were more
closely related to mako sharks
these pop culture shark monsters still
have an impact on the real world
scholars and scientists have proven that
negative portrayals of sharks in the
media fictional or otherwise directly
correlate to how people conceptualize
the real deal even reputable networks
like the discovery channel capitalize on
the shark monster phenomenon with faux
megalodon documentaries or serial killer
shark mysteries
these fictionalized shows rely not only
on campy entertainment value but on
humanity's appetite for positioning
natural species as supernatural monsters
the fish becomes a serial killer a
spectral figure a monster
many sharks today are facing the threat
of extinction primarily because of human
actions
threats to shark populations include
fishing fin harvesting pollution habitat
loss and climate change it is estimated
that 100 million sharks are killed every
year for commercial profit
as apex predators the removal of sharks
from the food chain has a catastrophic
effect on marine ecosystems
today some scuba divers seek out shark
encounters looking not for monsters but
for beauties honoring the animals by
respecting them and studying them not
demonizing them
sharks aren't devious man hunting
killers we made them monsters fight or
flight jesus did we we did conquest
whoa
did i say vagina right again wrong again
hooper